et
[Musique]
l'astro l'une shadoks ne peut pas partir
les shadoks 9 refuse de pompey pour leur
faire peur le devin plombier est allé
réveiller la légende en ce temps là en
effet chez des châteaux il y avait une
vieille légende qui courait et quand
elles le tour f1 c'est qu'elle était
parti se coucher ou qu'elle était tombé
dans le fossé
alors on l'attrapé assez facilement le
de 20 pompiers l'avaient enfermé dans
son robinet est il la faisait parler le
soir à la veillée pour faire peur aux
shadoks malades et les faire pour op
elle disait pas mal de bêtises
elle disait autrefois sur la planète
shadoks qu'il y avait un ministre à
monstres terrible qui n'avait qu'un oeil
et qui mangeait tout ce qu'avait le mal
de lune
elle disait qu'il avait été condamné à
errer dans l'espace le monstre mais qui
n'avait jury revient très vite et se
vengerait et c'est sur eux qu'il se
vengerait s'il voulait pas pompé voilà
ce qu'elle disait la vieille légende
et elle a ajouté que quand le monde je
reviendrai
et bien ce serait la fin du monde par
dessus le marché
mais ça c'était pas vrai c'était la
ville les gens qui inventaient les
vieilles légendes c'est comme ça que ça
devient vieux plus là parlent à tort et
à travers mais les shadoks ne une
légende aussi vieille que ça cela leur
faisait ni chaud ni froid
elle avait bien du mal à l'eau pour lui
donner un coup de main le devin plombier
regarda dans son robinet magique un
matin et s'écriant je le vois il arrive
il est là le des bouées pipés c'est dans
trois jours la fin du mythe des déchets
donc ne se disaient qu'ils sont figés et
attention plus que deux jours avant la
fin du monde et les shadoks 9 fourie j
pour la dernière fois je vous le dis
ponte et craignez car c'est demain la
fin du monde et à la veille d'un si
grand jour les shadoks 9 restaient
couchés belle mentalité
le soleil et la terre un peu plus tard
on fait autant
et à la faveur de la nuit
silencieusement et pas à pas tout
doucement le lendemain approchait et si
la vieille légende avait dit vrai
[Musique]